[Music]
we have great leadership here that
understands that uh one mistake
can uh be our demise um
one mistake can bring us all down in
in a real bad way and it's not just
coming to football it can create a
terrible illness so i want to dominate
when we leave the building we want to
crush this virus we want to beat this
virus into the ground
and i can use those words because it's
not on our schedule
that's right he doesn't have to say that
the virus puts its pants on the same way
we do
or whatever it is yeah the here's the
bottom line
winning this year is going to entail so
much more than the things that you
ordinarily do because the more guys you
can keep healthy
as it relates to the virus the better
chance you have to put your best foot
forward
and ideally every team will be able to
do it we don't want any team's
best performances to be squandered by
the fact that they've been careless when
it comes to the virus but this is part
of the effort and part of the reason why
chris i believe
that there's optimism now we'll see
whether the optimism is merited
that the players will do what they need
to do to keep themselves
clean and keep themselves from testing
positive and not being available to play
the raiders come in at number 22 on my
pre-season power rankings they did
finish seven and nine last year they
they had flashes yeah right remember
when they beat the bears in london they
made us think they beat the cult
there's a way to dig out of this yeah
they had a little run there
right but then it ultimately settled
down and when you consider all the stuff
they went through the antonio brown
it was just about a year ago when when
he had frozen feet
i was in cleveland right i think i was
doing the training camp tour
i just happened to say it on one of our
segments in the show because i had found
out and then it became news it went
downhill from there with the helmet
issue and then he wanted to be cut he
got
cut and the raiders didn't really have a
replacement they were pinning so much of
their hopes to antonio brown in their
passing game but they got
great performance out of josh jacobs
that one of their various first round
picks last year great running back one
of the finalists for rookie of the year
and uh year three for john gruden back
with the raiders chris
this kind of feels like even though you
have an excuse for not being very good
this year if that's what happened this
kind of kind of feels like the year that
if gruden's ever going to light that
fire this is the year to light it i
agreed i mean i think they've put
themselves at least in a position
to you know light that proverbial fire
like you're talking about finally with
their team i mean
hey i mean all honesty he took over a
team in the situation
they were crap they really were you know
they've had two phenomenal off-seasons
in a row
i would say in free agency and the draft
mike mayox done a great job there
but you know i think the big thing is
yeah you look at that john gruden the
system
they did some good things last year
derek carr certainly seems comfortable
they haven't had weapons around him now
what they did do and what you just
mentioned last year is they got one of
the best offensive lines in football i
mean they got road graders they got
killers
richie incognito trent brown uh
rodney hudson at center still a great
center in football they got the colton
miller guy at left tackle
you know the first round of room a few
years ago so they built something there
be with josh jacobs
and protecting derek carr now they got
some receivers
this offseason in the draft specifically
so
now i think was the chance at least for
the john gruden offense we're gonna go
okay let's see what this is all about
because you got the running game
they got a tight end and darren waller
that is one of the best tight ends of
football i'm not saying he's george
kittle or travis kelsey but he might be
the next guy on the list he's special
so there's something to build off and
that's where i get excited for the
oakland raiders i think they're one of
those teams where
you know i i maybe they go seven to nine
or eight and eight or nine and seven but
i think it'll be a different
look of their team this year and much
more exciting and i'm excited for that
and remember this year there's that
extra wild card birth yeah
conference eight and eight nine and
seven if you're in that territory
you're at least not going to be dead
until week 17 as it relates to your
postseason just a tough possibility we
know
now right well and that's the thing you
could be
the fourth place team in the afc west
and better than the third place and
second place teams in every other
division
in the conference but hey they better
get used to it with drew lock in denver
and patrick mahomes in kansas city and
if justin herbert
pans out for the chargers man it's going
to be a long decade or so for the
raiders until they find a franchise
quarterback and they thought they had a
franchise quarterback in derek carr they
continue to keep derek carr
but mike mayok the team's gm continues
to be
more candid than any nfl executive that
i can ever remember when it comes to
saying that the same standard that
applies to every other player on the
roster applies to the quarterback
always looking for someone better we're
not going to fail to try to upgrade at
every position including quarterback
there's been this sense that they've
been looking and wondering
and seeing what they could do marcus
mariota is in now as a
back up with some thinking that mariota
is going to do to derek carr what
ryan tannehill did to marcus mariota
last year you throw all that into a ball
chris
derrick carr is getting upset here he is
from yesterday
did i think about opting out um when
this thing came up
i did not uh i have a lot to prove to
myself
i have a lot to prove to to my
organization i'm i'm being completely
honest i'm tired of being disrespected
so there was no question i was going to
play this year i'll tell you one thing
in our quarterback group
we ha you have to compete that's what i
do you guys anybody who's around me all
i'm gonna do is compete
i've i've had multiple starters
in the nfl come in here and be in the
same room as me uh
you can go through the list about who's
started games and who's been in our
quarterback room
it happens all the time but when you go
7-9 people like to
make up stuff
uh look it's it really bothers me frozen
on that face
it really bothers him though and that
can i just say this yeah
since he's already got me blocked on
twitter i don't know how old derek carr
is now he's got to be getting closer to
30. he's north of 25. he's somewhere in
that range between 25 and 30.
i don't know at what age it's no longer
acceptable
to wear the the t-shirt where you've
gotten your own scissors out
and cut out extra material so you can
show off even more of your shoulder
like i thought that was a 20 21 22 year
old thing
i've been there i've done that but it
was a long time ago i
think the cutoff is probably 24
where you don't do that anymore i don't
know chris
i think you're a jerk i think that's
what you are but
you know he's wearing that because
that's what he wears under his shoulder
pads is what i'm guessing
it just feels better you know sometimes
it's a quarterback you don't want
this sure you don't like i'm sure he
likes to show him or
he wants to show his guns sure he didn't
change his shirt before he showed up for
his press conference
i know this is just what i happen to
have on i think it is
i'm gonna stick up for him there and
listen people rag on him and i
understand he can come off as you know
dorky at times i i get it yes i've been
around him before
he's not as dorky in person as he comes
off in interviews at times
you know that's good to know well hey it
is good to know he's he's cooler in
person so far
but you could tell it bothers him why
and that's where he's got to get over it
it's got to stop taking it personal just
worry about yourself derek carr you have
a lot of talent
you can be the franchise quarterback for
a long long time
and they put some pieces around him this
year oh oh hey
he's going to be the quarterback of the
raiders as long as he chooses to be
remember that from last year i do
remember
this this is the thing back when the
office was popular and it's
still popular now it's arguably more
popular than it was and it was on
tv and it's heading to peacock first of
the year
the michael scott was just that ultimate
awkward
no self-awareness guy and and and the
saying was
you either know i'm michael scott and if
you don't know michael scott
you are michael scott and i look at
derek carr and i think
he probably doesn't know a michael scott
he's just got that
way about him it's that lack of
self-awareness it's that awkwardness and
it's trying
so hard to not be awkward
trying so hard to be cool trying
too hard and i don't know maybe with
maturity he'll figure it out but that's
what that's just
how do you inspire a locker room full of
grown-ass men
when you have that element to your
personality well yeah i mean
okay that's a that's a legit question
you're right it's not maybe the type of
personality that's gonna rub off in a
locker room
uh he's gonna have to do his talking
with his work and his play you know and
which is what most quarterbacks should
do you know we think quarterbacks are
cooler than they are anyways because hey
they're handsome they make a lot of
money and we think whoa they play cool
quarterback
a lot of these guys are dorks you know
for lack of a better way to say that
you know a lot of my friends thought i
was a dork especially when i was playing
you know they your friends are very
perceptive yeah they're very they are
they're spot
on and i think because of maybe all
these things it's easy to jump on him
i and and that i i get and of course i
think he opens that
you know pandora's box to be jumped on
at times you know she comes out and
jumps all over him you know how
pandora's that's full
what's in pandora's box chris that's a
box full of pandora
but but i do i like derek carr's talent
he does have talent he has a good
you know a good brain he processes
information
what was the big thing i know i talked
about during our quarterback rank he's
got to let it loose and i think maybe
that's a little bit of
the personality we're seeing that's
going over you know he's letting
the critics worry you know dictate his
play a little maybe
to a degree let it go this year big guy
you got a good arm fire it around the
field
i don't care if you throw for 79 and the
greatest completion percentage ever
you need to make plays for that offense
and he's got the ability to do that
and now with ruggs and tyrell williams
and you know darren waller
and of course that run game and the and
other guys they drafted in the draft you
go
you know it's there for him to do that
this year and i just hope he takes his
advantage and kind of lets it loose this
year
and it doesn't help matters at all that
you do have a general manager no you're
exactly right it about his willingness
to go find someone better than they
opened pandora's box mike you're exactly
seven and a half they
yes and and i feel like what they're
trying to do
is needle him and needle him into being
a better quarterback than he is like
whatever that element is that we witness
where he does seem a little nerdy a
little dorky a little not self-aware
that that they're they're trying and
they they're
they're searching for the button yeah
and the latest effort to search for the
button is to go sign marcus mariota and
see if that's the thing
that finally gets derek carr to be the
guy that they think he can be
because that's reality he's got the
potential he just hasn't gotten
full performance out of that potential
yet no well you know and we saw a little
that potential
you know early on in his career what was
that the 2016 season when he got hurt
and
you know he was in the mvp conversation
and all that but i'll say what the
difference was then too
you know was he had talent around him
there at that point
there there was some receivers and some
people that you know could take
advantage of some of his plays so
you know maybe that button that they're
searching for in that magic way about
him
maybe that was just getting some people
around him that he felt confident okay
i can let it loose we'll see that's
certainly the big question
you know there's a lot to like on the
team but that's a big question
you know defense has been turned around
they did a good job there but
they have play makers guys that can
change the game on that side of the ball
i don't know but i do like the direction
the raiders are going
he was in the mvp conversation in 2016
until the thursday night game
in kansas city right that cold game he
yeah
he self-disqualified himself he did that
night and but he was
in the conversation that year he was and
and and i really do
think that you know his third season in
the nfl
and he he makes a splash
if you don't follow that up you really
do set yourself up for criticism because
you've declared yourself one of the
better quarterbacks in the nfl
he was the highest paid player in the
nfl for a little sliver of time i think
until andrew luck jumped him
or he jumped andrew luck no he jumped
andrew luck then matthew stafford jumped
both of them but there was that period
where it was like one domino after
another but for like a month he was the
highest paid player in the nfl
but then when you don't take that to the
next level or sustain that that's when
people start jumping on you and that's
when your team starts looking for
someone else
and that's what this has been i feel
like they've just been treading water
the past couple of years
waiting for someone better than derek
carr or waiting for a better version of
derek carr
either way they're not happy with where
he is right now i think that's very fair
what you just said and i think that's
what it is mike
it really is you know gruden you know
john gruden
he listen i heard this crap when i was
playing he wants quarterbacks that can
make plays
he wants guys that can take the pressure
off him and the offense at times
that's why you know if you've ever
listened to him the years when he was
doing monday night football he would
drool over guys like aaron rodgers and
people like that
that's why he was drooling over kyler
murray in the draft last year
because he's going damn i could never
call the right play all game wrong and
this guy could probably make some plays
and still make our
my offense look good that's what he
wants from derek carr peed him a little
little
little light as lightest right he has a
stat that i think
really kind of says a lot about derek
carr derrick carr
has the most losses in nfl history
with throwing ten plus passes and not an
interception in that game
to me that is a stat that i love because
pete's listening
but exec you know it amplifies what i
was trying to say about
yeah that's great you know completion
pers you got to you got to make some
plays to go win the game every now and
then you got to
you got to do something and when you're
to your point when you're making 25
million a year and they want you to be
that guy
go ahead start pushing the boundaries a
little sorry
but i vividly recall you explaining the
way that john gruden is with his offense
his offense is a ferrari
he doesn't want you to scratch it much
less crash it and
is that why we've seen a conservative
john gruden has him afraid of his own
shadow i i don't doubt that
i think there's there is a little that
there too yes you know john one day
could tell you to be careful
don't do this don't do that and then the
next day he'll be like hey cut it loose
big guy i need you to go out there
and make plays today and yeah you can
get a little bit like wait which
guy am i dealing with here today is this
you know take care of the ball gruden or
be aggressive and make plays gruden
and he's gonna have to find that fine
line he is and then and
at some point he might just have to
mother f john gruden every now and then
like rich cannon used to do i mean rich
cannon used to walk off the field and
you see seven swears coming out of his
mouth because he's telling him shut up
you didn't see that coverage you didn't
see that guy in front of me
and i think it'll go a long way when
derek carr does do something like that
with his team and everybody they're
gonna be like oh
look at our quarterback it really could
maybe help him out in the situation
but i think that's what has been going
on for the last
two plus years in oakland and now las
vegas
trying to get whatever there is
that fire within derek carr to take over
and at some point at some point when
you've tried
everything when you're out of carrots
and you're out of sticks
you just have to say it ain't there
right
that's the test this year for derek carr
is there something inside of him
with all and we played the video he's
he's upset you could see it okay so
maybe it's burning now show us
yeah now show us right now show us
because if you're not going to show it
on the field this year
you're done as the quarterback of the
raiders
period and and he should embrace this
kind of stuff he shouldn't get
mad and go hide in the corner and block
people on twitter he should stand up and
say screw you i'm going to show you what
i had
that's right that's that's exactly right
just go out there and show us
and you know like we've said too you
know i think the exciting thing for
derek carr and gruden and everything
there is
yeah we talked about some of the talent
the offensive line the running back
you know he can let it loose this year
they're going to have support around him
gruden's going to put together a good
game plan he'll stay patient with the
run game
and they're gonna have to win games with
their offense this year
that that to me is the next step here
their defense hey corey littleton
nick whitakowski and free agency yeah
it's
great you know the the draft picks uh to
help their team but they don't have a
guy on their defense where you look at
and go
oh that's a khalil mack or you know
that's an errand
they have nobody that can sway a game
that way and we saw that last year their
defense was incapable of closing games
out in some of these close games
so you know derek carr i think is going
to have to push the envelope a little
bit this year with
offensive explosion and aggressive plays
because i don't think their defense is
set up as young as it is right now and
still
kind of growing that that's going to win
them a whole lot of games
look they they have the talent it's not
going to be easy
in this division uh we just need to see
more from derek carr
and hopefully that anger that was
manifested yesterday becomes the theme
becomes the thing becomes the device
for him to stand up for him to show the
mental toughness for him to stick it
back in people's faces
and perform and not get bogged down
by worrying about whatever it is that
people may be saying
and whether or not the team is looking
for another quarterback all right best
case worst case
for the las vegas raiders this year who
will be playing before no fans they've
already announced that at their home
games no fans this year
what's the best outcome well
i don't think that i don't think
realistically i could sit here and think
best case the raiders sneak into a wild
card not right now
i can't you know i think they're a team
that i look at as best case like
you know a nine and seven eight and
eight maybe a ten and six team that's on
the
on the outside looking in i don't really
look at it that way i think they're a
team that's on the outside looking in
having a chance in december is the best
case worst case i don't see a really low
floor i don't know how you feel about it
mike but
i mean i would be shocked of anything
worse than
seven and nine or six and ten that's
about as bad as it gets but i really
think they're a team that will be
consistent and flirt with that eight and
eight kind of record
you've got a really tight window though
i know i know i don't see haters you're
right
and if the floor is where you say it is
uh they're playing the four teams of the
nfc south
this year they're playing the four teams
of the afc
east this year um i i could see them
be third place in the division
potentially
right they'd whether they can overcome
the charges of the broncos that that's
not going to be easy to do
but i could see third place in the
division and seven seed
i think that's possible that's the best
case for the best case would even be
making it to the sixth seed with
tiebreakers and whatnot yeah okay
especially with all the uncertainty over
covet 19. but you're setting a floor
that puts them in contention into the
middle of december yeah if you think
that the floor
is seven and nine six and ten yeah right
unless they're
three and ten down the stretch which i
don't think that'll be the case
six and ten yeah right so they're gonna
be in that remember that
seventh playoff spot is going to put
a lot more teams in play for the
playoffs
than we otherwise would have yeah so i
think they're going to be in contention
for seven seed maybe six seed and uh and
then they go to the playoffs and they
lose
in the playoffs and they decide as usual
next year the the the i i i hear you
there totally i hear you
as usual though the thing i always look
at right with the schedule yeah the
conferences they're playing and i look
at the start
you know and and that to me is going to
tell us a lot
going across country to play the
carolina panthers to start but then you
got to go
saints at home at the new england
patriots buffalo bills
at the kansas city chiefs bye week tommy
boy
and the buccaneers come to town i mean
that's that's legit right there
so uh they're gonna have to be on their
p's and q's and ready to go when they
when they hit the
you know hit week one and make sure
they're ready to run
yeah uh well we'll see how they turn out
but uh
definitely not the easiest of divisions
for the las vegas raiders not the
easiest of circumstances
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports